wenn ludwig danko sich auf den weg macht
ist irgendwo im land ein unternehmen am
ende das war schon vor corona so er ist
insolvenzverwalter auch in der
wirtschaft trifft es zuerst die vor
erkrankten heute ist ein schwächelnder
autozulieferer fällig
gruner ist auch hier in der tat
letztendlich wahrscheinlich der auslöser
gewesen locker ohne allein ist natürlich
nicht verantwortlich für die insolvenz
insbesondere werde die hna group
es gibt schon seit geraumer zeit
umsatzrückgänge und das unternehmen ist
auch in einzelnen teilen nicht optimal
aufgestellt
die dbh group geht bereits zum zweiten
mal in die insolvenz corona ist nicht
ursache der pleite sondern gibt ihr den
rest das unternehmen bis zahlungsunfähig
für diesen fall schreibt das gesetz
einen insolvenzantrag vor die dgh blick
zwar auf 100 jahre markterfahrung zurück
doch wie so viele in der autoindustrie
hat die geschäftsführung der mobilitäts
wandeln zu spät sonst genommen was uns
nach hinten geworfen hat ist einfach das
thema wie verändert sich die
autoindustrie was ist mit der e
mobilität wer wusste nicht kommt die e
mobilität wann kommen zu würzen
massenmarkt wird es keiner und dieses
fragezeichen lässt ein jahr vorsichtig
agieren im klartext der druckguss
spezialist braucht ein neues
geschäftsmodell die insolvenz also ein
schuldenschnitt soll einen neuanfang
ermöglichen das insolvenzrecht hat auch
eine funktion bei der für die wirtschaft
so wichtigen marktbereinigung ja
insolvenz ist durchaus ein probates
mittel
der begriff insolvenz negativ behaftet
ist wir werden auch negativ behaftet ist
aber es ist auch ein sehr gutes mittel
restrukturierungsmaßnahmen durchzuführen
da wird immer vorrangig das thema
personal genannt aber das ist ja nicht
allein
man kann in der situation durchaus auch
verträge die unglücklich gefasst sind
vereinfacht kündigen
man kann mit lieferanten andere
konditionen verhandeln und bis auf
weiteres ist der vom gericht eingesetzte
insolvenzverwalter danko hier der chef
rund 600 arbeitsplätze stehen insgesamt
auf dem spiel
danko stimmt bei der
mitarbeiterversammlung auf harte zeiten
ein
es wird das hatte ich auch von anfang an
gesagt das wird auch zu
personalmaßnahmen das wird jetzt relativ
schnell gehen
sie werden also nicht weiter im
ungewissen bleiben ob und wie die
personalsituation die personalplanung
weitergeht wir müssen sehen dass wir so
lange wir möglich durch halten um dann
zum schluss zu denjenigen zu zählen die
längerfristig am markt als zulieferer
existieren können hinter
personalsituation und planung verbergen
sich schicksale jobs gehälter
familienhäuser kredite existenzangst
sandro richter hofft trotz der insolvenz
an bord zu bleiben
nächstes jahr hätte ich mein 20 jähriges
jubiläum
wulff war hoffe dass man das noch
erleben kann und ob das ist dann eben
schon nachhaltig gibt wie es weitergeht
anders als die dgh werden in pandemie
zeiten viele unternehmen in deutschland
vor einer insolvenz künstlich bewahrt
für danko ist das augenwischerei
niemand wisse jetzt welcher
geschäftspartner schon vom pleite virus
infiziert und welcher noch gesund sein
die landläufige meinung dass mit der
aussetzung der insolvenzantragspflicht
alles gut ist und man einfach so
weitermachen kann
die liegt natürlich völlig neben der
sache das ist einfach falsch die
erfahrung zeigt dass die wirtschaftliche
situation in der regel ja nicht besser
und möglicherweise das unternehmen aus
der situation der sich dann befindet
wenn man dann zu einem sehr späten
zeitpunkt insolvenzantrag stellen völlig
rettungslos verloren ist also gar nicht
mehr sanierungsfähig ist normalerweise
ist die insolvenzstatistik ein
seismograph weniger insolvenzen heißt
der gesamten deutschen volkswirtschaft
geht es gut doch die korona bedingte
wirtschaftskrise ist aus der
insolvenzstatistik nicht abzulesen im
gegenteil
im vergangenen jahr haben so wenige
unternehmen insolvenz angemeldet wie
zuletzt vor über 20 jahren
der grund nachweislich von der pandemie
geschädigte firmen dürfen auf einen
insolvenzantrag verzichten
diese änderung im insolvenzrecht hat die
bundesregierung im vergangenen frühjahr
beschlossen und bis diesen april
verlängert eine entwicklung die gabriel
felbermayr präsident des instituts für
weltwirtschaft mit skepsis betrachtet
denn die pleitestatistik hat sich zum
ersten mal in so deutlicher form von der
realen lage der unternehmen entkoppelt
wir sehen eigentlich dass in rezessionen
die insolvenzanträge steigen das würde
man ja auch vermuten da fehlt das geld
da fällt die nachfrage
unternehmensforschung nicht gutging
ändern pleite und ist auch wichtig
insolvenzen spielen in der
wirtschaftlichen dynamik eine große
rolle
es werden hier ressourcen frei gemacht
für die branchen die wachsen sollen
deswegen sehen wir das mit sorge wenn in
dieser schwersten rezession der
nachkriegszeit die insolvenzstatistik
keine aussagekraft hat welche folgen
kann das dann noch haben für die
wirtschaft im wirtschaftlichen leben
brauchen wir verlässliche information
möglichst wenig unsicherheit und
deswegen ist die insolvenzordnung auch
so wichtig ihre rolle ist es
informationen über meine
geschäftspartner transparent zu machen
das fehlt dann schwindet das vertrauen
wenn das vertrauen schwindet dann werden
weniger transaktion stattfinden
dann sinkt die wirtschaftliche dynamik
doch unsicherheit ist gift für das
wirtschaftliche miteinander
wiesbaden anfang november auch in der
event- und kommunikationsbranche sind
die verheerenden folgen der pandemie
nicht zu übersehen
jörg ist eine der führenden agenturen in
der unternehmens- und ereignis
kommunikation noch im frühjahr herrschte
hier kreatives chaos und rege
betriebsamkeit
jetzt sind von 53 festen mitarbeitern
noch 18 dabei der geschäftsführer hans
reitz setzt sich weltweit für die
entwicklung sozialer projekte ein
verdient sein geld als kreativ berater
für große unternehmen
26 jahre lang ging es stetig bergauf
der macher erfolgsverwöhnt bis coruna
kam das sind um jobs rückgänge zwischen
60 und 65
da war begann und natürlich noch viel
schlimmer dass keine plant das kann er
sich traut die qualität um kredite gehen
natürlich dahin wo sie sich vermehren
können das heißt die fliesen nur
anpassen und dann bleibt für die branche
in der ereignis kultur in der event
branche in der live-kommunikation im
moment natürlich ist das nicht der
bereich wo man heute schon investiert
hans reitz ist jetzt viel im home-office
dass bald wieder veranstaltungen und
konferenzen stattfinden wie einst vor
der krise schwer zu glauben
seine firma will er um jeden preis am
leben erhalten
er kämpft um aufträge entwickelt
digitale veranstaltungskonzepte reicht
das zum überleben
auch noch nur so darum wie kann es
weitergehen
in welchen rollenverständnis können wir
zusammenarbeiten
hans reitz braucht kredite mit einem
volumen von 3 bis 5 millionen euro um
das jetzt schon verlorenen jahr 2021 zu
überbrücken
die schwierigkeit finanzielle mittel
aufzutreiben ist für den 54 jährigen
geschäftsmann vollkommen neue kraft
schöpft er bei seiner familie
vanessa spindler und hans reitz sind
seit elf jahren zusammen
sie macht sich mehr sorgen um ihn als um
die firma ich habe ihn oft gefragt warum
kämpfst du so nah und warum kannst du
nicht einfach sagen okay man muss jetzt
sachen ziehen lassen und neu anfangen
und er für sich alleine aber er fühlt
sich sehr verantwortlich für alles auch
für seine mitarbeiter und er möchte
nicht aufgeben und da kann ich noch drei
mal sagen ich habe angst du über wenn
die last bald oder schläft auch schlecht
und aber er kämpft eine insolvenz wäre
ein harter schnitt für den
leidenschaftlichen unternehmer loslassen
was ohne eigene schuld in schieflage
geraten ist eine bittere entscheidung
auch für die mitarbeiter kämpft hans
reitz stone schweizer auf du jetzt kommt
die steuer nächste woche
und dann gibt es das 24 26 und wenn wir
nächste hals lauf kommt sie vom gehalt
sowie als live
in neuss leitet patrick ludwig hand im
bereich wirtschaftsforschung bei
creditreform einer große auskunftei die
daten zur kreditwürdigkeit von
unternehmen sammelt seit beginn der
krise warnen experten wie hans vor einer
pleitewelle was wir tatsächlich fürchten
dass in krippen effekte
das bedeutet wenn die staatlichen
hilfsmaßnahmen wie beispielsweise das
kurzarbeitergeld die überbrückungshilfen
oder auch die aussetzung der
insolvenzantragspflicht ganz kassiert
werden dann wird es für die unternehmen
noch mal besonders schwer denn ohne
diese subventionen ohne diese hilfen
werden viele in dem ihr in der jetzigen
situation vor dem aus stehen welche
rolle spielt vielleicht auch die
tatsache dass in diesem jahr die
bundestagswahl stattfindet keine partei
kann es gebrauchen dass wir steigende
arbeitslosenzahlen haben keine partei
kann es gebrauchen dass wir eine
insolvenz werde bekommen und man wird
alles tun um das zu verhindern der
wirtschaftsexperte befürchtet die welle
von firmenpleiten werde nicht verhindert
sondern hinter die wahl geschoben
das war für unternehmer zu falschen
entscheidungen und treibe viele in noch
größere not ein beispiel aus hannover im
logo bietet der herrenausstatter rolf
eisenmenger seit 20 jahren hochwertige
anzüge nach maß an
doch die anlässe für den feinen zwirn
fehlen nun schon länger von zehn
mitarbeiterinnen musste er bereits fünf
entlassen
eisenmenger sitzt auf ware die er schon
bezahlt hat und auf einem schuldenberg
der 66 jährige hat einen kfw kredit in
höhe von 500.000 euro aufgenommen
meine altersversorgung kann nicht
klicken weil man altersversorgung steckt
in diesem betrieb hier an dieser gmbh
als darlehen von meiner seite als
gesellschafter darin ich kann dieses
geld die nächsten zehn jahre
aufgrund der inanspruchnahme von kfw
mittel nicht herausnehmen
das heißt ich werde nichts anderes tun
als die nächsten jahre erstmal weiter zu
arbeiten so lange zumindest bis die
firma mit anderen stadium ist wo ich
über einen möglichen verkauf nachdenken
kann im guten glauben an die zukunft hat
raiffeisen menge entgegen dem trend auch
noch im sommer weiter in sein geschäft
investiert
viele hochzeiten die abgesagt wurden
verlegt wurden verschoben werden all die
anderen
es wird irgendwann nachholbedarf
eintreten der einführung strichen
tsunami von auszahlen auf uns zukommen
wenn dieser tsunami kommt dann wäre das
mit sicherheit nicht schlecht zwei läden
zu haben plus der mietvertrag von
unserem alten geschäft läuft im nächsten
jahr aus das heißt wir müssten so oder
so neu aufstellen und man kann mit dem
moment hat ersparen gesagt man wird mit
dem wissen heute kein einzel mehr
schließen
das wird nicht noch mal passieren daher
sagte es wird nicht noch mal passieren
kann wenn zweites geschäft aufgemacht
es ist wirklich teil unserer
entscheidungsgrundlage gewesen sein
ausgeprägter unternehmergeist kommt
eisenmenger jetzt teuer zu stehen
bis mindestens mitte februar wird der
einzelhandel geschlossen bleiben der
herrenausstatter verdient so gut wie
nichts mehr
ich bin geschäftsführende gesellschafter
der gmbh ich bekomme keine arbeitslosen
gehört ich zahle auch keine
sozialversicherungsbeiträge
ich bekomme zwangsweise auch kein
kurzarbeitergeld ich bekomme auf gut
deutsch gar nix ich muss in die firma
noch gelder einlegen wenn
schwierigkeiten entstehen und der vater
staat hat für uns als unternehmer kein
unternehmer geld vorgesehen
wir sind auf gut deutsch die für die es
keine lösung gibt
die insolvenz rückt immer näher er
befürchtet bald pleite zu sein
eine stabile beziehung gibt halt gerade
in zeiten andauernder sorge rolf und
seine frau sind seit 35 jahren
verheiratet corona ist nicht nur ein
wirtschaftsthema für die beiden
ich bin risikogruppen meine frau ist
risiko coco ho 3 trotz allem habe ich
momentan vor dem virus keine angst ich
habe angst vor meiner zukunft und habe
angst gegen altersarmut zu verfallen
das macht mir mehr angst als der vero
sie für rolf eisenmänner ist es ein
täglicher kampf mit den zahlen den er
nicht verlieren möchte mit dem
insolvenzverwalter volker römermann
spricht er deshalb frühzeitig über
möglichkeiten der sanierung falls eine
drohende zahlungsunfähigkeit nicht mehr
abgewendet werden kann
da haben wir die klassische
insolvenzverwaltung oder wir haben die
eigenverwaltung eigenverwaltung heißt
dass man als geschäftsführer schon noch
weiter auch das ruder in der hand hat
man kann die geschäfte auch noch selbst
weiterführen
unternehmen können schon jetzt die
instrumente des insolvenzrechts nutzen
um aus der krise zu kommen statt immer
tiefer rein zu rutschen insolvenz in
eigenverwaltung diese chance nutzen
verstärkt große unternehmen wie das
prominente beispiel galeria karstadt
kaufhof aber auch für kleine und
mittelständische unternehmen könnte man
dafür die zugangshürden runterschrauben
stattdessen setzt die regierung
weiterhin auf die aussetzung der
insolvenzantragspflicht die regierung
gibt das signal den unternehmen etwas
gutes zu tun wenn sie keinen
insolvenzantrag stellen
aber ist das wirklich etwas gutes für
das unternehmen denn letztlich züchten
wir zombies es gibt immer mehr
unternehmen die obwohl sie eigentlich
zahlungsunfähig sind trotzdem noch am
markt bestehen weil sie auf diese
unterstützung aufbauen
experten warnen je länger die krise
dauert je länger die
unterstützungsmaßnahmen desto größer
werde die zahl derer die nicht mehr auf
eigenen füßen stehen können dadurch dass
der staat massiv in das
wirtschaftsgeschehen eingreift stark in
wirtschafts mechanismen eingreift dazu
wird er vielleicht sogar zum
schutzpatron einer sich
verschlechternden volkswirtschaft und
das muss durchbrochen werden wir müssen
es schaffen dass der staat nicht mehr
die wirtschaft lenkt sondern dass die
wirtschaft sich selbst wieder lenken
kann
doch vom selbstbestimmten wirtschaften
sind viele unternehmer gerade weit
entfernt
im dezember treffen wir hans reitz
geschäftsführer von der eventagentur
circ wieder
er versucht auch weiterhin jeden monat
die gehälter seiner mitarbeiter zu
zahlen
das eigenkapital längst aufgebraucht ist
gar nicht mal so was wirklich ruhe oder
einfach mal durchschnaufen sanken aber
das braucht es noch 100 tage sind sieben
tage woche über eigenes haus also das
war also schon immer gerne
das ist schon sehr viel das aber noch
nicht das geht mir sehr sehr sehr sehr
knapp die hilfe nicht da waren und wir
sind nicht ankam noch nicht warum mir
helfen natürlich dann auch weiter aber
bis zur ersten dezember das jeden tag
auf sicht fahren wie es die nächsten
drei tage weitergeht ist zunächst fünf
tage weitergeht
auch wenn bald weihnachten ist die
finanzen lassen hans reitz nur wenig
zeit mit der familie mindestens einmal
die woche spricht der unternehmer mit
seiner steuerberaterin wie steht es um
die liquidität welche anträge müssen
gestellt werden welche verbindlichkeiten
bestehen nach außen viviane krudewig hat
heute zunächst schlechte neuigkeiten für
ihren mandanten ist noch nicht gerettet
es kann
zu hause haben also bei stehen wir mal
so viele arbeiten
wir sind wirklich in einer sehr
angespannten situation gerade im bereich
der agentur ist es definitiv so hängt
natürlich davon ab dass auch dort das
planen schwierig ist wann könnte der
events stattfinden welcher form werden
sie stattfinden dass die agentur über
den berg ist kann man definitiv nichts
sagen es kommt wirklich darauf an dass
die hilfe nicht schnell kommen die
agentur circ ist durch krone deutlich
geschrumpft
um wieder so wettbewerbsfähig zu werden
wie vor der krise muss reizt das
unternehmen auch personell in die alte
größe zurückführen
dafür reichen die staatlichen hilfen die
er bisher bekommen hat nicht aus beim
sehr kamen wir bis jetzt nur die
überbrückungshilfe bekommen nur ist wo
gesagt dass wir sind wir natürlich sehr
dankbar
da braucht man sich dem november und
dezember hilfe noch und wir kämpfen noch
um den kfw-kredit den braucht man wenn
man den den wir das alles geregelt
bekommen dann sind wir wieder
selbständig und mündig um unsere sachen
fahrrad zu sagen corona infiziert auch
die wirtschaft staatliche hilfen sind
für den patienten alternativlos aber es
werden medikamente verabreicht die in
der zukunft mehrkosten könnten als sie
nutzen was fehlt ist eine klare
überprüfung bei wem sich eine behandlung
überhaupt lohnt denn überschuldung und
unsicherheit sind langfristig gefährlich
nicht nur für die unternehmen selbst
sondern für das gesamte
wirtschaftssystem und damit für den
wohlstand von uns
[Musik]